[موسيقى]
العرب والقمر بينهم علاقه حسيه ومعنويه
الحسيه دليل الحساب عندهم والمعنويه رمز
جمالهم فالقمر ما ينفك عن الثقافه العربيه
بكل مجالاتها الحياتيه بل والعقائديه
فقدماء العرب عبدوه وكانوا يسمونه بود
وقالوا لا تدرون الهتكم ولا تذرون ودا ولا
سواعا ولا يغوث ويعوقا ونسرا فشهرهم يبدا
عند ظهوره هلالا بحيث مغيب الشمس غربا
وينتصف عند تبدله وينتهي عند ظهوره هلال
النحيلا قبيل شروق الشمس شرقا خسف البدر
حين كان تمامه وخفى نوره فصار ظلامه ودرار
النجوم غارت وغابت وضياء الافاق صارت
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وتنقسم اضاءه القمر الى قسمين القمر
المتنامي ومعناه ان الاضاءه تتنامى فيه
وهذا يكون من اول الشهر الى منتصفه والقمر
المتناقص ومعناه ان الاضاءه تتناقص فيه
وهذا يكون منتصف الشهر الى نهايته وخلال
المتنامي والمتناقص يمر على وجوه عده هلال
تربيع اول بدر تربيع ثخير وهلال اخر الشهر
واجملها مرحله البدر الوجه بدر والعيون
كحيله والفم مثل شقائق
النعماني
[موسيقى]